after a rainstorm lily measures the
depth of several puddles in her backyard
she records her results in a table so
here are three different puddles and she
measure measures the depth in inches and
then we're asked how much deeper was the
puddle under the swing than the puddle
on the sidewalk so pause this video and
see if you can figure that out
so they say how much deeper was the
puddle under the swing so that's this
one right over here that's one and
one-fourth inches deep it's under the
swing how much deeper was that than the
puddle on the sidewalk let me do that in
a different color the puddle on the
sidewalk and we see here the puddle on
the sidewalk is two-fourths inches deep
so we could do is subtract the
two-fourths from the one and one-fourth
so we could write one and one-fourth
minus
two-fourths
we could write it like that
and we could try to subtract the
fraction part two-fourths from the
fraction part of this mixed number up
here from one-fourth but we immediately
have a problem because two-fourths is a
larger fraction than one-fourth so how
do we deal with that
well the key is to realize that one can
be rewritten as a fraction one and one
fourth is the same thing as
one and one fourth is the same thing as
one plus one fourth which is the same
thing as another way to write one in
terms of fourths is four
fourths so this is four-fourths plus
one-fourth
plus one-fourth which is going to be
equal to five-fourths so now you can
view this as five-fourths this number is
the same thing as five-fourths minus 2
4. let me rewrite it minus
2 4
minus 2 over 4 and that's pretty
straightforward if i have 5 of something
and i subtract 2 of it i'm going to have
3 of that something in this case i'm
talking about three fourths so this is
going to be three
fourths so how much deeper was the
puddle under the swing than the puddle
on the sidewalk well three-fourths of an
inch and just another way that you could
have visualized this is look i'm going
to subtract two fourths from one and
one-fourth at first we could have
thought of one and one-fourth as a hole
like this
and then so let me shaded the whole in
that's one and then i would have a
fourth of a whole so let me divide this
into four equal sections
so this is one and one-fourth and at
first we said well how do we take away
two-fourths from just that i only have
one-fourth right over here and our key
realization is well look i actually this
hole right over here is actually four
fourths i could think of it as four
fourths so i could think of it like this
and now i have five fourths one two
three four five fourths and now i could
take away two of the fourths so i could
take away one of the fourths and two of
the fourths and what am i left with well
then i'm going to be left with
these
three fourths
right
over there